Faustine hollow est devenu le plus jeune
joueur de l'histoire des échecs à
dépassé les 2300 élo à seulement 9 ans
et demi exposant au passage tous les
records de précocité alors quelle est
l'histoire de ce petit produit de la
surnommé par les médias argentins le Leo
Messi des échecs
commence sur le confinement où il
apprend à jouer tout seul sur Youtube
encouragé par son père qui n'a pas très
envie qui casse tout dans la maison avec
son ballon de foot pour l'instant
c'était à continuer il lui propose une
récompense dès qu'il gagne 100 points
l'autre sur Chess.com dès la première
semaine le petit fossile va avoir son
papa trois fois pour réclamer son Dieu
devant un tel succès ses parents
l'inscrivent dans un club en ligne ou
professeur propose des maths en 4 coups
à résoudre là où les autres enfants à
peine le temps de voir où sont placer
des pièces fausty a déjà trouvé la
solution face au phénomène ses parents
décident de lui prendre un entraîneur
particulier il a ensuite enchaîné les
succès avec notamment une victoire
contre Étienne Bacrot lors d'un title
Tuesday l'octube champion de France et
un piqué l'eau à 2800 bits sur chet.com
reste désormais plus qu'à savoir
jusqu'où montera le petit prodige
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]